given how difficult it has been to
achieve global climate change goals how
do you approach this to get done what
you need to get done knowing how
difficult it is across the world well it
is difficult but so is Solar Impulse and
they're already showing that investments
there in technology can actually do
amazing things despite the fact that he
couldn't hear us but Andre and Bertrand
the other pilot are truly showing what
technology can do so for Paris what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
marry the advance of policy with the
advance of technology and the advance of
finance all of those need to actually
advance together in order to be able to
get us on to the two-degree pathway that
seems rather impossible but it was also
impossible just two years ago to fly
around the world with no no fuel just on
solar so you know when we unleash human
ingenuity we can make the impossible
very possible all right well it sounds
great but let me let me like put a
little something to that like like you
could pencil out the improvements in
solar and imagine hey everyone's gonna
have solar on their rooftop in Africa
and everyone's gonna have a hundred
thousand dollar Tesla and then our
problems of emissions are going to be
substantially reduced but that probably
wouldn't be a realistic way to make
goals for a summit that's gonna happen
just a few months from now how do you
marry the possibility of technology with
the reality of the slow adoption of some
technology well actually there are
walking hand in hand so the reality is
that even just last year much more more
than half of the new generation
investment was already in turin obols
you already have last year 10 times as
many patents being filed for renewables
than you do for traditional fossil fuels
and the IEA the International Energy
Agency has just released a report that
tells us by 200 and 2030 that is only 15
years from now we the renewables will be
the leading source and solar just to
look at solar let alone you know wind
and all of the others but just solar has
had an absolute
the incredible price drop 80% price drop
since 2008 and increasing in it in its
efficiency and then of course to be
added to that the incredible investments
that are being done in storage because
that's the weakness of solar of any
other renewables right what do you do
what do you do with that excess energy
when you're not using it because you
have to be able to use it when the Sun
is not shining or when the wind is not
blowing so you know the combination of
the investment into solar coming down
and battery development is absolutely a
very very powerful combination